ciao a tutti allora avete presente i
film brutti quelli brutti quelli che
quando dice brutto ti si stava pure un
po lecito per te allora ho scoperto
recentemente fatto che i registi hanno
trovato un escamotage dei loro film per
farti diventare interessanti una cosa il
film diciamo che va avanti in maniera
orribile e tu del presidente che vuoi
uccidere di quei chi ti piazzi lì ti
vedi questi qui che parlano fra di loro
e stai lì lì per spegnere lì lì per
premere stop destroy band i suoi bei
uccidi d'ora qualcun altro che la scena
super geniale parte la sa mai visto le
sue cose possiamo inserire il tessuto
ecco qui ma come detto che te frega
riina veramente no cioè adesso ditemi se
non sono furbi e ci sono arrivato
solamente adesso le domande qui mi
voglio porre e vi voglio voglio
condividere su 12
la prima come gli girano queste scene
nel senso io mi immagino il regista che
sta lì a urlare e che gli dice forza
ragazzi più così più colate avete
presente con i registi in preda alla
crisi artistica tanto alla fine
diciamo leveranno il suono e metteranno
a posto del suono quelle specie di menu
di e melense col sax rumori del mare che
azione
coraggio ragazzi allora così siamo un po
moscetti ha lasciato per dire tardi di
più buttate ok così nati qualche suono
qualche movimento un coinvolgimento
emotivo un coinvolgimento coinvolgenti
vi lasciate che il fuoco
ecco quel fuoco della passione nasca
all'interno di voi ci sia quel bonus 21
capito è un che sale capito ragazzi è un
cerchio che funge katia lo metti come
dire un pochino più di passione suono
passione bocca pochi occhi bocca e
passione geremia un pochino più macho
mostra che mi piace musica chi sei in
loro una forza e si condomini forum
ragazzi che conosco non ci siamo
geremia se tendinopatie sigaretta
ecco guarda negli occhi a primo cerca di
dare qualche colpo capito è così
seconda cosa che mi chiedo spesso capita
che la protagonista però non sia una
faida senso che prendono un bidone con
gli anfibi come come ragazza perché
perché serve un cesso e la cosa
interessante che cosa fanno
non potendole far fare queste scene un
pochino così sensuali le fanno fare
solidamente alla figlia di turno che che
ne sono della sorella che compare nel
film solamente per quella scena che
l'hanno proprio brisa solo per quello
della domanda è come glielo fanno il
provino cioè io mi immagino una cosa
così ok la prossima se non sbaglio
dovrebbe essere ma claudia ciao a tutti
ciao avanzato fa quando quando sei
pronta
questa pubblicità basta così grazie e
complimenti
grazie a voi che molti fermo saperli
insomma ecco le mans anche la piazza
ragazzi voglio anche ringraziare per i
video risposta che avete messo sono
veramente carinissimi i divertentissimi
quindi anzi se potete metteteci anche a
questa verità tanto che vi cosa siete
bravi
[Risate]